I'm saying this now first of all you're
not me uh no one knows who you are is a
social media megastar I point you you
trained however long you want and Logan
fights ksi I'm gonna tell you I'm gonna
knock you out with the right hook it's
gonna really get knocked down the first
okay boom instead she's a [__] it's
crazy I thought you guys are a desease
dude I'm down on the camber don't you
family watching you
[__]
[Music]
daddy's coming in wearing your face on
his on his crotch
whatwhat does that mean opening question
they're just gonna have your face on his
pelvis well he like it like after that
we did it face to face like after like
his fans were like yo Dez yeah I like
you but like you're making it hard for
me to root for you and I think he like
just like it's digging himself in these
in like deeper holes like bro like he
tweeted that and like everyone everyone
roasted him and I was like sitting there
like do I respond to this like do I just
tell him he should like delete his
Twitter like no one even sees the cup
like the cup go like that he he has my
face on his cup but that goes under the
shorts like I think he's just like you
got issues what what yeah what if what
if you win and then afterwards yes to
like take a shots off and then look at
the cup I guess that's why I don't get
like it's just weird as [__] in general
like it's just super weird even the
blood that's really bad blood between
you guys cuz you two started it all the
right before really you got the beef and
before it was Logan and JJ didn't it was
like you and Daddy were going at it
didn't eternity your [__] house or
something like that or was it your old
house I think was my old house yeah for
views I've seen this guy no I mean I get
it like I mean he was trying to hype it
up I think what desi doesn't realize is
that like he started this whole thing as
like a game and like a joke and like oh
this will be fun and like I'll get
involved with this because my youtube
channel is dying but like he doesn't
understand that I'm so serious about
this and that like I have put 150%
effort into every single moment of my
day since learning about this fight and
I think that's weird edgy like I he's
he's like caught up in the he's caught
up in the hype you seen all of the is he
training with the Darla's he not as he
over the side man is he not what do you
thinking when you're watching all of
that
I think it just I mean again I don't
really know like what they're beefer
like what the problems are but I think
it's like why would like what why would
you not want to train with your brother
and with a better trainer and like have
someone else to push you like we've had
like when we're training like we've had
days where it's like bro like we don't
want to be doing this right now but I
look over and like he's feeling good and
like I have to pick it up and like
watching him spar I learned from him
because we're both beginners like
there's so much benefit in like training
with someone else I just think it's like
another weakness and like just
something's not right there like I don't
know what it was like I could never
imagine like I would hate training for
this about myself like it'd be lonely I
wouldn't work as hard like I don't know
when you spoke each other on the phone
early on in this you were like come
although I've got the box and gloves he
was that I need time to train and what
were you think that money was going
through all these phone conversations
with him do you think you were serious
so I never know I never thought he was
serious
his his big point was always like why
don't you fight ksi why don't you fight
ksi and I don't think I don't think he
was serious I and even when he like went
back to the UK and like sat down and
like mate made his video like saying
that he would fight me like I was like
surprised I was like what like why why
do this and I tried to like put all the
clues together and to me like the only
thing that I can get out of it is like
this is just like a chance for him to
like revive like his brand like his
career and like his YouTube channel I
think that's what he's like mainly doing
this for and like he gotta got caught up
into it without like even realizing and
then he like kind of just went for it
after that what does this mean to your
career cause like you've got like as you
say probably the youngest audience of
the fall guys and in the main event and
these kids are kinda like gonna be
surprised probably when they tune in and
they say
because it's not just your fight I told
you in the car like people are gonna
really be going for this to make a name
for themselves on the show are they all
your fans ready for that I don't know I
think I think they were definitely like
they're definitely ready I think they
they're excited I don't know if they'll
know like what to expect or like you
know a lot of it will be like foreign
territory for them but yeah for me like
for me this is just like it's bigger
than for me this is bigger than just a
fight and I think that's what like my
fans can connect to like I I haven't had
like the easiest like past year as well
yeah hook though and just like ups and
downs friends this that the stuff with
like the Logan situation and I feel like
this is almost like a shot for me as
well to like to like win and like not
not and and just for myself like for me
personally like just a show and like
proving to myself that all of this like
crazy crazy [__] happened and I was able
to stay focused and work towards
something and like and defeat it and
conquer it and like really I I guess
like as well as like really showing
people like who I really am mm-hmm
cuz you guys get connected a lot just
like other brothers do exactly when
you're in there as much as its brother
versus brother you're on your own
and this is about what you are made of
and like when you look at like tell me a
little bit about the last year because I
know obviously the team 10 stuff
happened like what was that like when
people who you depended on on now saying
I'm walking away like how did that feel
it's crazy like I it's crazy but at some
point like you have to understand it but
it's like it's the weirdest feeling in
the world like literally kids who have
been best friends with since like
seventh grade wake up and are like oh
there's a moving truck here like peace
out and they're not even like adult
enough to
have a conversation with me about it
it's like it's such a mind like cluster
I've never been through something like
so crazy did you did you ask yourself
the question of like am i approachable
because I'm sure like to some people
you're pretty intimidating block you've
got this whole media company around you
you in this big name did you feel like
you left yourself open to them to be
approachable or did that not cross your
mind I don't know 100 percent I would
talk with these kids on a day-to-day
basis I would I would help them with
something as little as like finding a
maid to clean the room because like
they're new to Los Angeles and like they
don't know anything - like how to
negotiate a six-figure brand deal - like
how to film a YouTube video - like how
to deal with hate - like being their
friend like I feel like you're being
used in it sorry didn't rip you but do
you feel like that but yeah no 100% I
think I think that's that's like because
I've seen like you know you we all watch
drama and all these and like it goes
back performers like Jay Paul use me and
then I didn't make a single till this
day I haven't made a single dollar off
of team 10
I've only invested my own money into it
to make it successful and they're like
oh like you owe me this you did it like
that like there's so much like back and
forth and it's all I wanted to do is
create a platform for people like
accomplish their dreams and a lot of
them have but they still don't they
don't I don't think they realize like
what they had until it was gone and I
definitely feel like when you blow up
overnight and you basically like don't
have to do anything and like
everything's given to you and like all
of a sudden you wake up and there's like
five to ten people in your ear like a
manager an agent being like yo come do
this deal come on this you like Oh what
why you with Jake like why are you
giving him a percentage like all he did
was just like gets you to a million
followers they start to believe that and
they're like yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and they like feed
into it and do you regret doing to your
tongue no I don't I don't I don't I I
think if you think about it if team 10
work together right now it would be that
we'd be bigger than the Kardashians I
don't know if your office's as good as
Kim's to be honest we've booked no I but
I don't regret doing it I think it I
think it it's still an amazing thing I
think it's just about finding like the
right people like there's obviously
members who have stayed throughout all
the [__] and like those are the
right people and we will continue to
grow and and find those people who are
actually ready to be a part of something
amazing and not just like immaturity and
I think like as we've seen like members
leave team 10 you see them all turn into
nothing and make mistakes and and fumble
and then I think they're like oh [__]
like maybe what I had was was amazing I
don't know that just how I that's just
how I see it and a lot of them like try
to like text me and like on the road up
to this fight have you seen people come
back towards you like or whatever a
little bit a little bit I think because
they know this is gonna be a huge event
and if yeah I mean I think they just
like again I realized like damn I
screwed up especially because like I'm I
was like with these people every single
day like we were best friends like every
single person that has ever been on team
10 we were actually best friends and I
think like ones that friendship is gone
they're like oh like they kind of like
almost realize that and they don't they
want that back or they like are feigning
for it or something but at one point we
were all best friends
so it's like it's kind of like this it's
a kind of crazy I admire what you try to
do with that like I watched an interview
did with The Breakfast Club where you're
saying like you know you look at these
entrepreneurs in hip-hop and you
thinking all right who's gonna be the
first do to do that on YouTube why not
me this makes sense do you know me yeah
so moving into the fight you're in
training come all of a sudden you what
was your aesthetic back when it was that
similar law of instantiating in what was
your athletic background did you do oh
yeah I wrestled play basketball football
I was like before I moved to Los Angeles
I was like 32 and for my junior year of
wrestling you have over like 150
wrestling matches well not commit how do
you think knowing what it's like to
compete in maan against my thousand
percent it's there's no feeling like it
in the world like going again like team
sports are great but there's no feeling
in the world like you've been in a ring
or on a mat with somebody and only what
like one of you has to be a loser and I
know Deji hasn't had that feeling and I
know in his head he thinks he knows that
feelings like he's lost a couple of she
so much let's be honest today but but on
the day of the fight like he's gonna
know what that's like I think
speaking of like they can't lose
documentary it's like how JJ was the day
of the fight he was just like scared
like that's the feeling that dead she's
gonna go through and it's like
inevitable it really is how do you view
can't lose because you're about to go
through a lot of what you're watching in
that documentary what did you take
anything from it oh yeah I mean when
when the case I tweeted like yo Logan's
gonna watch can't lose and he's gonna
see how like screwed he is or whatever
when I watch it I was I was like this is
me being like flat out out
dislike off camera I was not impressed
by how hard they were working why not
it just seemed it seemed like going
through the motions
there was no like excitement and like
and like reasoning behind it I remember
at one point like JJ was like 40 minutes
late to like a practice I don't know
like just just little things like that
that I picked up on then you feel like
your dedication is is a both oh yeah
five times that and that's me personally
like I logon has a harder fight and
Logan's dedication is even even how do
you know about Logan's fight genuinely
you feel like you can do this a hundred
percent there's no better person like I
remember I remember watching him like
Rhett in wrestling because I was always
looking up to him like I was always two
years younger and like I would read it
yeah I was at Rachel I would wrestle
first and then his matches would be
after mine and you see like how much
fight and determination he has and how
not only that but how calm he can stay
and like in crazy moments like I
remember it was like the biggest
wrestling match like against his biggest
rival for like the third time and like
the score was like 14 15 and like till
the last second he was like fighting to
like get these last points and like that
just that just like who he is as a
person and not only that but his size
his athleticism his power strength is
are you support together no with a coach
won't let us
but I've seen I've seen people walk into
the ring sparring him and like they get
out of the ring all right yeah
so speaking of logged and you've you've
watched him go through a major thing
this past year what was it like being
his brother and seeing you know the law
and then coming into this fight I mean I
think the difficult the most difficult
part was like how like I always wanted
to like respond back to the people
mm-hmm and be like this is who he is
that's not who he is you don't get this
situation you don't know like what his
mindset was you don't know how he deals
with like shitty situations like the
giggling and the laughing and [__] like
that like I wanted to like respond to
people but at the same time I was like
he [__] up and like he does have to
learn from that and he has and I think
even I I've had to learn from him
learning from that like he's taught me
like I've learned from his mistake what
was it like that week for you generally
like good because you I would imagine
you probably got tarred with the same no
it's like a [__] Paul Brothers like
yeah you know like well that's something
I got looped into all of it which which
sucks because like I didn't do anything
but just by like guilty by association
and then they started bringing up like
[__] that I had made mistakes on in the
past and like lumping it all into one
but we started this together and like
we're gonna end this together like we
moved from Los Angeles we didn't really
know what we were doing but we wanted to
be actors and entertainers and change
the world and that's how this whole
thing started and so regardless of all
the [__] we just have to like keep on
pushing pushing through that have you
envisioned what its gonna be like on
fight night like when you're in there
and you know you're the bad guy as well
I guess everyone
and to be fair on the press conference
and I've said this multiple times I was
really surprised at how you dealt with
it the way you come out and pull like
what oh yeah what [__] fair play man
like you handled it well but you're
gonna have to handle ten twenty times up
in the ring aren't you yeah I don't
think it'll affect me at all
I know actually I know it won't affect
me at all I'm so worried again I'm so
focused and I visualized the whole
entire night from arriving to the arena
til going to sleep that night victorious
every single moment I've already lived
it in my head and I'm I see it so
clearly and like I feed off of that
energy and I love to prove people wrong
like my whole entire life I've been
proving people wrong and like that crowd
will be proved wrong hopefully in the
first round and that's just that just
like how I am like are you driven by the
naysayers generally like it and does it
some people it gets to them when people
say they can't do that bit it feels like
you and your brother both like it
suppose you're on it does people like
since our since we since we started my
teachers would literally like come up to
me in class and be like what are you
gonna do and vine dice you're not oh
you're going to Los Angeles like good
luck
talk to my peers being like oh you want
to be an actor like that's funny like
have fun in Los Angeles we'll see you
when you don't make it in three months
and that's always driven me I think
that's like because anyone said anything
about boxing like button to you I mean
yeah like I mean like tweets and yeah
and obviously like what Deji has said
he's brought up friends family my
girlfriend what was that like for you
you're not I mean it pissed me off but
again I did it it just made it worse for
him
because when we're running I like have
that video of him talking [__] about my
girlfriend and grayned in my head and
like when I'm running I'm tired every
morning that [__] just plays in my head
and I'm just running faster and so this
is personal for you as a yeah and it
just that that [__] talking has made it
worse for him
it feels cuz I spoke to Jay Jay about
this and now I'm desi up but Jay just
seemed to feel like you guys are a good
like because he called you both out
basically it felt like you guys were
good the biggest names he could find to
make his name off of sort of thing he's
treating this is strictly business and
in his approach do you worry that you're
by thinking about that obsess no you
might get a little bit too emotional in
the ring
no no because one thing I have a lot of
his composure and I think at the right
moment when when Deji is seconds away
from being finished that's when the
anger is gonna come out and that's when
he's gonna really feel it that's kind of
what happened with Jay Jay and Joe
actually Jay Jay was already composed
and then right at the end when Joe was
as I say I'm doing that I visualized
everything like literally I will be the
more calm fighter and when I needed to
pull that out when it's daddy's last
seconds that will come out and that's
when the fight will be over how have
your friends and family reacted to the
fact that you're gonna get in the ring
and do this they've been super
supportive I mean we've always watched
fighting growing up and it's kind of
like in the family and so they're all
gung-ho about it like I remember telling
Anthony my best friend he was like yeah
brother like you got this [__] I was I'm
a little nervous for like Erica
she's like I don't think even like she's
been like we went to a UFC fight but
it's obviously scary like for your loved
one to be like in a ring but she's been
super supportive and like it's a lot
it's a lot for the friends and family as
well and like people just around us
because of how much we're training and
how dedicated we have to be to this and
she's had to make sacrifices as well as
I've had to make sacrifices and so it's
been amazing to have like that support
system around me who's who are all 110%
about it when you were first learn how a
box did you feel like it was coming
naturally you or were you struggling a
little bit
oh no I felt I felt supernatural I think
the I think the wrestling helped a lot
with this is like just movement in
general but yeah there's definitely some
points where I felt stuck but just
getting into it like it was natural and
I have watched like fighting growing up
so I was able to like kind of like pick
up things and like remember things that
I that I had seen and like anything that
I do I want to be the best at it and so
I went into practice like every single
day like just fully focus like I caught
up a finger you [__] song when you
say no seriously I would go into
practice fully focused like phone down
three hours four hours of time like just
dedicated on this that's hard well
because where as YouTube got the guys
where you used to just being like being
doing everything everything to do and
we've got the [__] phone in one hand
we think about this we've got managers
probably everybody's I want him to talk
to you so to tell everyone who would
normally get your time like [__] off of
this reales was that just a bit of a
challenge at the start it was it was I
think people got used to it after after
a little while after like they'd be like
oh we have a meeting at that blob a lot
of time and I'd be like an hour late and
like
training like I could give a [__] about
this so he was Eddie get used to it what
was like when you look back at this
training come what was there a day that
stands out that was the hardest day for
you where you like [__] that was the
worst day yeah there was a day it was
very early on where I got my ass handed
to me
in sparring like I was just off like I
think I got into an argument with
someone like right before we started to
practice like I just got my ass beat and
it was like I was like holy [__] like
I'm I'm bad at this like I can't box and
I just like went back watched the
sparring footage and just like made a
note of like everything that I did wrong
and the next day it was like my best day
how honest are you with yourself I feel
like we as youtubers like you're kind of
used to watching your videos back and
analyzing what went right well yeah
trying to help a little bit yeah for
sure I I do that with every sparring
session you know like just watching back
the footage and analyzing every single
moment and and seeing like what went
wrong and like I said that was the worst
day like I like was I got my ass beat by
someone who was smaller than me shorter
than me
weighed less than me oh god I'm so full
yeah it's just so hot I was like okay
all right but then I came back the next
day fought the same dude and I think I
think almost like knocked him down but
yeah I just had to mentally be like let
me get over this hump in like that and
that's the worst I'll ever do until
August 25th I've seen some footage come
out recently if you've not been this guy
out the ring there's a lot of people
saying fake it's this that what's the
story with that so I mean I was firing a
dude and he flew out of the ring he
didn't want the smoke what Kevin people
people I like that people are sceptile
skeptical on like whether it's real or
not
I think was the way he fell oh look a
bit weird but people when it's a non
fighting audience watching a sparring
session a little is they always seem to
think they're faked like it so what
about Deji spawn you because when Deji
first started learned how to Train like
we all see in the way that was going and
what were you thinking when you were
watching his early videos I was on I was
on tour at the time so I was kind of
just like is this like I don't know if
he was like joking or not but I thought
they were real for the record yeah no I
know that because I found a video like a
year before all those of him sparring
ksi in there like kitchen or some [__]
and like same thing he got hit once in
the stomach and like flew to the ground
but yeah I was just like is this a joke
like I really want him to take this like
seriously and I think at least he was
like starting but and I was on tour at
the time so I wasn't really even
training but how long you been training
for this really since the day I got off
to her like I I wasn't really able to
Train hold on Google um since June 25th
or well two months I'm gonna have two
months of training that's not why you
did that Instagram video where you were
like this is me now and you posted it a
month yeah yeah
what was that about what you're just
trying to get in this hair though I know
a guy who said think about it
if there's no footage of me out there
and I put out a video July from July
first on August 1st and everything I do
in that video is better than what he is
doing currently I know for which I know
for a fact he's not hitting the bag as
good as I am he's not jumping rope he
doesn't have the footwork he he's not
getting punched in the stomach every
single day by a 20 pound medicine ball
that in Daddy's head he smelled like
damn
the past month like I haven't been
training this hard as this kid and that
I know isn't it said our final question
make prediction how does this end what
me how does the door fire and I'd like
that I really I really would like to say
a knockout in the first round
I do see deadly getting into the ring
and and just running from corner in a
corner he doesn't inspiring videos he
goes from corner he runs this way it
goes this way he he's flying all over I
think again he's not I don't think he's
prepared to go six three-minute rounds
so I think maybe after he gets tired in
the first round or second round and he
stops flying around the ring there's
gonna be a knockout like I said
hopefully it's in the first round we'll
see we'll see where his skill level is
that there's there's almost no footage
of him out there but there's no way he's
better than the Jay Jay that was in the
Joe Weller fight and that's just as a
younger brother he's thought we was
measuring him off no I don't think so I
think that definitely does play into it
because it's like there's no way dad you
work harder than KS I did for the Joe
Weller fight recruit and I'm 5 to 10
times better than KS I was in that Joe
Weller fight and so there's some sort of
there's got to be like crossover yeah
okay thanks for coming on me yeah sure
good shot